und wir bleiben einfach mal beim thema
kameras bayern das land bayern hat in
dieser woche für seine polizisten den
einsatz von so genannten body camps
freigegeben er gibt es in immer mehr
bundesländern zum schutz der beamten und
ganz ehrlich man wundert sich dass heute
überhaupt noch irgendwer freiwillig
polizist wird
passen sie auf ich werde jetzt gleich
die aufnahme starten wenn sie ihr
verhalten nicht ändern
werde ich jetzt gefühl ich habe ja oft
das gefühl dass ich gefilmt werde meine
damen und herren ich konnte nie beweisen
ich wollte doch nur sagen unsere polizei
ist unterbezahlt unterbesetzt und hat zu
wenig nachwuchs
das ist so es ist einfach so gut was man
sagen musst du erlebst schon eine menge
in dem job haben sie das mitgekriegt
haben sie das mitgekriegt wie jemand der
die feuerwerkskörper abgebrannt hat ich
bin besorgt über das ja dann noch viel
spaß dabei ja viel spaß wenn blaue auf
blaue treffen sage ich nur gut die
beiden die wir gesehen haben brauchten
jetzt mal keine body cam aber
tatsächlich ist die hemmschwelle
gegenüber vollstreckungsbeamten stark
gesunken in deutschland was gewalt
angeht aber auch was den allgemeinen
umgangston angeht
[Musik]
also ich würde lieber nach hause gehen
verständlich verständlich
wenn ich das so sehe muss ich sagen ich
werde direkt zu hause geblieben aber
aber nicht nur kameras sollen unsere
polizisten den schützen sondern auch
ganz neue polizeigesetz und man kann das
tatsächlich so zusammenfassen widerstand
gegen die staatsgewalt fängt bei uns
jetzt schon deutlich früher an soll
jemand zb von polizisten abgeführt
werden und schlägt dabei im reflex den
arm des polizisten weg während das
mindestens drei monate haft also ist
bestimmt gut gemeinte problem es gibt ja
zum beispiel bei demonstrationen auch
mal fälle von exzessiver polizeigewalt
gegen bürger also die gibt es das ist
theater und und wenn dann wenn dann die
betroffenen anzeige gegen die polizei
erstatten dann folgt praktisch immer
direkt mehr gegen anzeige wegen
widerstand also ich sag mal so man darf
polizisten schon anzeigen aber
statistisch gesehen kann man es
eigentlich auch lasse
im jahre 2017 gab es 2177
ermittlungsverfahren gegen polizisten
wegen rechtswidriger gewaltausübung 91
prozent der verfahren wurden eingestellt
nur rund zwei prozent der verfahren
endeten in einer anklage oder mit einem
strafbefehl ja nur zwei prozent werden
angeklagt oder verurteilt aber hey das
sind immer noch mehr als bei den abos
ackers in fällen von polizeigewalt
ermitteln hinterher polizisten gegen
polizisten was soll da rauskommen das
nennt man chorgeist deswegen fordern zum
beispiel die linken eine bundesweite
unabhängige beschwerdestelle für solche
fälle wieder andere wollen
namensschilder für die beamten
und das ist doch läppisch namensschilder
für polizisten die verbrecher die
straftäter tragen auch keine
namensschildern liebe freundinnen und
freunde
ja ich finde schade oder namensschilder
für verbrecher finde ich gar nicht so
schlecht oder
ich finds geil ehrlich aber
die idee ist nicht schlecht da
übrigens so eine neutrale
beschwerdestelle hilft auch polizisten
oder würde auch polizisten helfen wenn
die sich zum beispiel über mobbing durch
kollegen beschweren ist die karriere
hinterher gelegentlich im eimer
natürlich sind das ausnahmesituationen
in dem gewalt angewandt wird deswegen
trainiert man das hier regelrecht hier
zum beispiel mit einem reporter
mein kiefer tun müssen das ist normal
dass nicht an ihn so um ihre
arbeitsbedingungen kann man
polizistinnen und polizisten in
deutschland jedenfalls sicher nicht
beneiden und deshalb müsste eigentlich
auch die nachwuchswerbung deutlich
realistischer seien hier original spot
der polizei hinten raus minimal
bearbeitet kommen zur polizei
auch nach vielen jahren immer noch neues
entdecken
der kontakt zu menschen weil hier für
mich ein kindheitstraum in erfüllung
geht weil wir einfach kein anderer beruf
ein feld der diese einmalig beschissene
kombination bietet aus mieser bezahlung
und uralte ausrüstung hier der kollegen
letztlich gerade an fragt sie und die
anderen limit im kampf gegen das
verbrechen
[Musik]
im letzten jahr die deutsche polizei
insgesamt 22 millionen überstunden
gemacht rekord und trotzdem gibt es
polizisten die von ihrem gehalt keine
familie ernähren können
das überhaupt nicht lustig in münchen
hatten im jahr 2017 immerhin 15 prozent
aller polizisten einen nebenjob als uns
einfach nicht reicht so das waren zwei
punkte und eine salami
das ist eine ecstasy und er liebe
extremen personalmangel dient ihr keine
andere branche bietet da gibt es so
wenig kollegen erwartest du im
durchschnitt 2 20 minuten nach einem
notruf die polizei und wenn die polizei
nicht hart genug ist wie wir es mit
sanitäter und dann bin ich dort genug
ist wie wir es mit feuerwehrmann
einsatzkräfte in deutschland das wünscht
man keinem
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen die ihre dreggsagg michl liegen
und ihr lasst jetzt slx ein beschissenes
abo da
[Musik]